[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et avant de teddy bonjour tout le monde
comme ça avant le savoir être et la
première des compétences développées par
l'académie des dalons depuis huit ans 17
promotion de jeunes se sont donné une
nouvelle chance de réussite va demander
à monsieur cinéma les deux baignades et
à planter des moments protocolaire qui
donne un cadre à ces jeunes qui ont misé
sur la cour pays pour construire leur
avenir
de nouvelles compétences qu'ils ont
partagé avec les enfants du quartier
est-ce que vous avez aimé cette activité
pourquoi vous avez mais cette activité
[Musique]
au moins 15 euros la maison un jour ils
vont porter leurs propres légumes
[Musique]
reconnaître la valeur de la jeunesse
pour qu'elle puisse faire grandir la
société de demain
voilà la dynamique de cette institution
départementale à l'action premier des
départements c'est l'aide sociale
et c'est les jeunes 18 à 25 ans et des
gens en europe est assez l'association
ce qu'ils font trois mois ici au bout de
trois mois après je crois qu'ils vont la
situation en entreprise et c'est un
petit peu comment l'armée c'est les
classes et puis après aller ailleurs
c'est très bien cette restitution se
termine devant les représentants de plus
de 85 partenaires de l'académie des
dalons et surtout devant tous ses
éducateurs qui croient en notre jeunesse
les adjectifs qui met plus la jeunesse
et nous fait mon stage est que la
jeunesse si les ont cas de la
magnifique
[Musique]